it's another day of protests for people
gathered here it's a silent sitting to
demand their rights many are from Mostly
Christian fishing communities in the
southern Indian state of Kerala they've
been camping here for 135 days we think
the pope will lead to our eviction our
lives and livelihoods have been
destroyed it's also my duty to save my
community for future Generations
the shipping Port is being built in the
virinyam region the project costs 900
million dollars but construction has
torn since the protest began the
government has accepted most demands but
is not ready to scrap this project the
court has ordered construction to resume
last week some were arrested for
stopping construction material this
angered protesters some of whom attacked
a police station at least 80 people were
injured in the violence cases have been
registered against 160 protesters some
people are supporting the project these
include Hindu groups close to the
governing BJP which have held counter
protests Justice should Prevail and the
port should be built appropriate action
should also be taken against those who
attacked the police station
authorities say the port will increase
trade and create job basically in the
East Court there is a lot of CEOs
happening everywhere not only in Kerala
not only in 200 even if you talk about
Karnataka even you talk about
Maharashtra there is a sea erosion so
people need houses for those people who
ever lost in Crows and they need houses
so the the reasons are now I'm not
saying whether it's genuine or not but
not pertaining to William International
C Port Limited the government has
increased security to prevent further
violence there are concerns the standoff
could spark religious tensions in this
area protesters say they'll continue the
agitation until they get Justice
Southern India